gerade hatten wir den
fraktionsvorsitzenden der afg im
bundestag gibt es gab zwei eine
doppelspitze und die
fraktionsvorsitzende des bundestages das
ist alles weiter und ist jetzt bei uns
vorbei die rede von jörg nolte hat hier
ziemlich eingeschlagen da war auch von
der bundestagsfraktion die rede er war
nicht sehr freundlich zur eigenen partei
auch zur bundestagsfraktion wie haben
sie das empfunden sich als angriff
empfunden des parteivorsitzenden auf die
partei auf seine eigene partei also das
muss jeder selbst für sich bewerten
möchte mich dazu nicht äußern ich denke
mal jörg menten hat sich das sehr genau
überlegt in seiner rede heute
wir haben ja ein programmparteitag zu
den themen soziales und da hätte ich mir
natürlich auch mehr programmatische
aspekte in dieser rede des
parteivorsitzenden gewünscht aber er hat
sich dafür aktiv entschieden ist eben
nicht zu tun
und damit müssen wir alle umgehen und
jeder muss das für sich selbst bewerten
und ich habe das auch nicht als angriff
verstanden wir als fraktion das was ja
auch thematisiert hat wir haben ja
gehandelt und dementsprechend ziehen wir
uns den schuh auch nicht an
er war ja sehr unter beschuss in den
letzten monaten gewesen auch von ihnen
da ging es zum beispiel um den rauswurf
von andreas kalbitz ist das sozusagen
jetzt die revanche gewesen
an der partei zu sagen wir sind wir
hatten einen konflikt miteinander und
jetzt sage ich euch eigentlich was ich
davon alles halte also dieser konflikt
der sollte hier überhaupt gar keine
rolle spielen und ich würde das auch
insgesamt nicht zu hoch hängen
das ist ja alles jetzt durch das thema
das wird auch hier keine weitere rolle
spielen es ist wichtig dass
meinungsverschiedenheiten
den vorstandsgremien ausgetauscht werden
und man muss nicht immer einer meinung
sein ich war ja damals für eine
juristische prüfung von wenigen tagen
dass das nochmal alles komplett durch
geprüft wird dass wir dann kann hin und
her haben so wie wir es eben auch
gesehen haben daraus aber wieder drin
ist er doch raus ist aber ein
hauptsacheverfahren das hätte ich mir
anders gewünscht aber es ist eben die
mehrheit des bundesvorstandes gewesen
und die müssen wir uns alle beugen und
wir müssen weitermachen denn wir gehen
ins wahljahr hinein also wir gehen in
die bundestagswahl wie in baden
württemberg wir haben auch landtagswahl
also dementsprechend konzentriere ich
mich vollkommen auf die
wahlkampfvorbereitungen bereits aber er
stellt ja den erfolg der afg in frage er
sagt wir werden nicht akzeptiert werden
wenn wir immer aggressiver werden er
wirft der partei mangelnde disziplin vor
inkompatible wortwahl hat ja einige
beispiele gebracht das ist ja auch
wichtig für den bundestagswahlkampf im
moment ist es mit den umfragen nicht so
gut wie vor einem jahr oder im jahr 2017
ist das nicht wichtig dass die partei
klar sich klar macht wofür sie steht um
dann erfolgreich nächstes jahr in den
bundestagswahlkampf zu starten so wir
sind eine partei die seit 2013 existiert
mit einem grundsatzprogramm mit einer
vollkommen abgerundeten ausgereiften
programmatik und ich verstehe auch daran
die kritik nicht
er hat auch kritisiert dass sich die afg
zu sehr gemein machen würde mit der
bewegung der querdenker da gebe es zu
viele verschwörungstheoretiker zu viele
die die wahrheit auf den kopf stellen
würden
es sei nicht klug sich mit denen gemein
zu machen und sich zu solidarisieren
wie sehen sie das wie sehen sie das
verhalten der querträger am rande dieser
demonstration am vorletzten mittwoch gab
es ja auch im bundestag die bekannten
ereignisse ausgelöst von mitgliedern
ihrer fraktion
sie sind die fraktionsvorsitzende wie
gehen sie damit um wie gehen sie
einerseits mit den querdenkern um und
mit dem vorwurf des parteivorsitzenden
die partei wird es sich zu sehr gemein
machen mit dem querdenker
also erst mal wenn sie die störer im
bundestag ansprechen
dort müssen die abgeordneten
konsequenzen tragen
und hier müssen wir feststellen dass
auch in der vergangenheit mit zweierlei
maß gemessen wurde wir hatten letztes
jahr so eine kleine bomben aktion von
extension rebellion während an der
namentlichen abstimmung muss nur
geknallt hat im deutschen bundestag
diese leute waren gäste von anderen
politikern von anderen abgeordneten im
deutschen bundestag
da habe ich mich auch gefragt wo da der
mediale aufschrei gewesen ist wir als
fraktion tragen die politische
konsequenz aber ich sehe eben auch
medial dass hier völlig mit zweierlei
maß gemessen wird die die abgeordneten
haben sich ja auch dementsprechend
entschuldigt und darf einmal ganz
abgesehen
diese eine aktivistin die da auch mit
rein gebracht wurde hat auch mir das
handy ins gesicht gehalt ich kannte die
ich fand das unwahrscheinlich
aufdringlich und das ging ja auch gegen
die eigenen fdp-fraktion da wurde unsere
büros gestürmt da gibt es ja auch
videoausschnitte und ich finde das
unglaublich impertinent bis 1
sie haben ja auch die frage gestellt zur
querdenken demo ich wäre extrem
vorsichtig die querdenken demo über
einen kamm zu scheren so wie es auch
teilweise formuliert wird in
irgendwelchen rechten
verschwörungstheoretikern wenn man
einmal über die querdenken demo gegangen
ist und querdenken hat letzte woche
völlig zu recht eine demo angemeldet
gegen das infektionsschutzgesetz dass
auch aus meiner sicht höchst
verfassungswidrig ist da kann man
wirklich per notstand gesetz am
parlament vorbei sowie das gerade praxis
ist sämtliche regelung auch einen
gerichten vorbei erlassen das ist
verfassungswidrig und die leute sind zu
recht auf die straße gegangen
und ich kann jedem empfehlen der
versucht diese bewegung zu diffamieren
sie haben überall querköpfe mit dabei
das haben sie auch bei black live meter
bei der antifa die auch höchst aggressiv
ist auch da verstehe ich nicht wo der
mediale aufschrei bleibt weil wir dort
eine aggressive bewegung haben aber ich
kann nur jedem empfehlen einfach mal
eine querdenken die
zu besuchen also was die mediale
unterschiedliche behandlung an geld
zumindest für phoenix sagen wenn linke
aktivisten gegen die geschäftsordnung
des bundestages verstoßen und gegen die
sicherheit im haus erwähnen wir dass
auch sie haben jetzt gerade gesprochen
das sei verfassungswidrig das
infektionsschutzgesetz es gibt eine
notstandsgesetzgebung im grundgesetz die
kann auch angewendet werden wenn gefahr
im verzug ist würden sie denn auch noch
sagen so weit gehen dass das eine art
ermächtigungsgesetz ist weil solche
äußerungen kamen ja auch aus ihrer
fraktion bzw aus ihrer partei
also ich würde nicht in die in die
verbale trickkiste dort dort greifen und
mit kontaminierten begriffen hantieren
sondern es ist ziemlich klar dass dieses
gesetz verfassungswidrig ist
da ist an dem parlament vorbei
gesetzgebung einfach gesetzlich eingeben
kann
und sie müssen sich auch vor augen
führen was ihr seit anfang von corona
auch passiert wir haben eine
hinterzimmerpolitik wir haben eine kugel
runde zwischen kanzleramt und zwischen
den ministerpräsidenten die permanent am
parlament vorbei regelung erlässt und
erst nachher dem parlament und auch den
fraktionsvorsitzenden der anderen
fraktionen im deutschen bundestag zur
kenntnis gibt ich frage mich was das für
eine undemokratische praxis ist und
diese praxis die prangere ich an
persönlich ich halte das für zutiefst
undemokratisch wie hier der bundestag
fast auf null gesetzt wird und das
kritisiert auch unsere fraktion
das haben sie aber nicht exklusiv im
bundestag auch die fdp die linke und die
bündnisgrünen haben das ja schon
kritisiert dass die deutlich später aber
dass sie dass das parlament dazu wenig
reinkommt ich würde gerne noch einmal
auf das thema wortwahl in der afg
zurückkommen denn dazu hat ja jörg
leuten etwas gesagt es gab eine ganze
reihe von äußerungen letzten monaten und
jahren von judaslohn über vogelschuss
oder messer männer einer dieser äußerung
stand der auch von ihnen ein
verfassungsrechtler hat ihnen ja der der
afg hoffentlich nahe steht ja trotzdem
ans herz gelegt sich im tonfall zu
mäßigen um eine beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz zu vermeiden denen der
afd
viele fürchten werden sie sich dann wird
sich die partei wird sich die fraktion
da in den nächsten monaten häufiger
überlegen was sie sagt was einzelne
mitglieder von partei und fraktion da
zum besten geben der öffentlichkeit also
wir machen das schon längst und darum
habe ich auch das jetzt noch mal dass
ein ex tänzer zu kritisieren habe ich
einfach nicht verstanden
wir tun das schon längst und wir stellen
nicht ehemalige npd auf wie das
beispielsweise in manchen ländern von
der cdu praktiziert wird wir haben eine
unvereinbarkeit liste wo beispielsweise
ehemalige npd dann nicht drauf also
nicht drauf kommen können als sie können
ganze unsere partei ein gegen andreas
kalbitz aber auch aus japan geflohen war
jetzt nicht angegeben das wichtigste in
organisationen mitglied wir reden jetzt
wenig von der npd also also die afg
stellt keine npd auf so wie es die cdu
tut gut
vielleicht noch eine frage zu dem was
gerade hier läuft auf dem parteitag
sozialpolitik da sich die afg ja auch
nicht einig sind dass er in die
wirtschaftsliberale mehr in die sozial
patriotische nennen sie ist anzusagen
sozial nationalistische richtung gehen
wird es war eine wird es leichter das
ist eine ein zitat aus einem
presseartikel sozialen nationalistische
stört sozial aber das machen sie jetzt
wirklich nicht
nein das ist ein zitat manche sagen das
sei ihre politischen gegner das sei
sozial nationalistisch was man da sagt
was was man doch nicht zu eigen machen
habe es zitiert ich habe es mir nicht zu
eigen gemacht und ich habe es zitiert in
welche richtung soll es dann gehen was
wird sich durchsetzen auf diesem
parteitag welche richtung das in letzter
zeit ganz ganz ehrlich
also so eine art der fragestellung auch
wenn sie es nur ca
nur zitieren die lehne ich ab ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen das was sie hier
gerade mich gefragt haben ob ihr etwas
national sozialen oder nationalen
sozialisten ist eine unverschämtheit
brüssel afrikanisch überhaupt gar nicht
unseren leitantrag gelesen haben der
sich mit dieser sozial politik
beschäftigt es ist ein kompromiss
zwischen ein mischsystem in der
sozialpolitik zwischen
umlagefinanzierung kapitaldeckung und
wirklich diese fragestellung halte ich
für unseriös und ich unterhalte mich
gerne ist da was mehr als fünf mal dass
manche wissen viele deutsche staat
wirklich sie sie normalerweise ich halte
das für unseriös die art der
fragestellung wie sie mir gerade die wie
sie mir gerade gefragt
also das ist mein knie hat aus
eineinhalb nationalsozialisten habe ich
nicht gesagt doch natürlich war etwas
anderes
gut dann hat frau weiter jetzt denn das
interview mit phoenix früher verlassen
das ist glaube ich nicht das erste
interview das alles weiterführt und
vorzeitig beendet wir werden aber schon
fast am ende gewesen
ja so weit dass in der eu mit der
fraktionschefin der fdp im bundestag
alles zweiten und